on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook organized censored a
government committee passes tech
companies to cut off Russell Brands
income have they abandoned due
processing dangerously overstep the mark
president zielinski is in the White
House to call for more U.S support but
can he would have Republicans who says
costing too much I'll talk to
presidential candidate will herd and
it's a British Countryside racist a new
report says it is or debate
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
from London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored in the five days since
allegations about Russell Brand were
made public he's been excommunicated
it's becoming a chilling case study on
guilty until proven innocent and how can
anyone now lose everything without any
due process at all as of today it's been
shockingly cheered on by the British
Parliament first brand was dropped by
his management companies live shows were
postponed his book deal with shelves
Netflix Channel 4 and the BBC have begun
quietly dropping his content but in
recent years brand hasn't relied on any
of those platforms for influence he
makes his money doing this
so how is this fire being used what's
the truth about it and why are there so
many conspiracy theories mainstream
media and state interests continually
use legitimate tragedies in an
opportunistic way there's a little
Wrinkle in this where people were trying
to set Ukraine up so that foreign
investment opportunities would be
presented is this in order to reverse
climate change and feed the world or is
it so that the entire process of food
from growing it to selling it can be
patented and controlled by Bill Gates
special catastrophes that ruin most
people's lives are beneficial to
financial Elites Wars that ruin the
lives of Ukrainian and Russian people
are beneficial to the weapons
manufacturing industry
now I personally think some of what
Russell Brown says is complete nonsense
and other stuff I agree with he's got
every right to say though what he wants
and he has lots of followers who love
what he says he has six and a half
million subscribers on his YouTube
channel alone the Google own company
though is now scriptures account of the
ability to make money at least for him
he can still post videos he just can't
take his cut now in a citizen
development an arm of the British State
he's pressing other platforms to do the
same Dame Carolyn Caroline dinage the
chair of the culture media and Sport
committee has written to X formerly
Twitter Tick Tock and Rumble these
alternative platforms where brand has a
big following asking them to drop it we
are concerned that he may be able to
profit from his content on the platform
she said we would be grateful if you
could confirm whether Mr Brown is able
to monetize his content if so we'd like
to know whether you intend to join
YouTube in suspending Mr Brown's ability
to earn money now Russell Brand is
accused of very serious things rape and
sexual abuse their grave allegations
reported meticulously by exemplary
journalism at dispatches Channel 4 and
the Sunday Times but they remain at the
moment accusations these are claims by
people by people who remained Anonymous
I think the conspiracy theories about an
establishment attack to crush the
dissenting voice are hogwash but I can't
think of a better way to Fan those
conspiracy flames and for a
parliamentary committee to intervene
like this as more people make their
living online we should be extremely
concerned about the ability of tech
companies to choose who gets to do that
and in a liberal democracy no one should
have more respect for due process than
Parliament it's not about taking sides
on Russell Brand if he's guilty he
deserves a punishment every bit is
severe as the alleged crimes he
committed but trial by MPS or trial by
Silicon Valley seems to me dangerous and
wrong
well to discuss I'm joined by daily wire
host Michael Knowles in America Michael
there are lots of strands to this
Russell Brand Story
but let's focus on one today which is
this what appears to be an extraordinary
overreach by the British Parliament
where the the chair of the select
committee has written to all these tech
companies demanding effectively that
they financially cancel Russell Brand
over allegations what is your reaction
to this
I'm glad to see that Rumble responded to
Parliament and said uh no we're not
going to cancel someone who hasn't had
due process of law based on mere
accusations without a conviction that's
really great it's unfortunate however
that YouTube didn't need any nudging
from Parliament YouTube decided to
demonetize Russell Brand right away
based on what based on some reporting of
decades-old allegations which may or may
not be true I don't know Russell Brand
has has been pretty open about having
been a derelict and a degenerate for a
long period of time in his life but this
is a very deeply concerning thing
because it's not just a matter of our
institutions turning a little bit
oppressive it's not just a matter of the
internet becoming less free with with
YouTube clamping down it's a matter of
our whole society do we have a free
Society or not well if we don't have due
process of law then we can't make any
claim to being a free Society any longer
right I mean I I don't happen to think
as many people seem to to judging my
social media there's been some
deliberate orchestrated mainstream media
attempt to gag and silence Russell Brand
so for what is worth I don't think that
is what's happened here I think this is
actually a SP a spillover from the me
too and time's up campaigns I think
they've been working on it for four
years some of these journalists and they
finally think they have enough to
publish these allegations against
Russell Brown and that's fine I read the
journalism with my former newspaper hat
on editor hat on I thought the the
journalism was perfectly well executed
but and it's a very important but it
they remain allegations and it seems to
me what's happening here is that the
British Parliament is now joining in in
a concerted effort by a number of
entities to effectively be judged and
jury on Russell Brand to preemptively
convict him of these allegations and to
punish him now that just seems to me on
every level that is that should not be
happening
this is a blurring of Institutions that
we've seen build up for years now you
see this especially on campuses if there
is a claim of sexual impropriety on
campus what happens do the students go
to the police and then there's a trial
over rape no what happens is a bunch of
professors get together in a committee
and they hold a kangaroo court and they
will they will be judged during
executioner they'll expel the student
without any due process of law and in
recent years we've seen that a number of
these have turned out to be hoaxes well
how did they get it so wrong because
professors are not supposed to be the
ones who are who are exercising the law
they're not they're not law enforcement
officers in the same way that Parliament
here is not supposed to be conducting
the trial certainly not Parliament and
the media put together and YouTube and
Rumble are not supposed to be enforcing
the law to your point peers I don't
think that there's a cabal of people in
a smoky back room somewhere saying we've
got to go get brand but it is convenient
that amid all of these sexual debauchery
that typifies Hollywood which we call
Gamora by the Sea over here you know
everybody virtually is involved in it
the people that tend to be held to
account even decades later are people
who speak out and so you look at someone
like Bill Cosby I have no doubt that
Bill Cosby did all sorts of nasty things
some of which may have been illegal but
I think that the reason the
establishment stopped liking Bill Cosby
is because he said things that were
Politically Incorrect and politically
conservative and the same thing goes for
Russell Brandt here the longer the the
time between the alleged crimes and the
consequences for those crimes the more
skeptical I am about the people who are
suddenly moved to prosecute yeah I mean
there's no doubt also that the way that
uh certain strands of the media covering
the Russell Brand Scandal is very
interesting because they've all pivoted
on their positions depending on how he's
been perceived with his own opinions in
other words when he was a left-wing
darling a few years ago he was sitting
in on the guardian editorial conference
references for example next to the
editor he was a highly prized columnist
there for a number of years he guest
edited the new States from the left-wing
publication you know he was appearing on
stage with big left-wing fire Brands
like Owen Jones and so on and it goes on
and on and on and he was lauded despite
his open bragging about his sort of
pretty depraved sexual activity he did
it to me in a GQ interview talking about
you know just a phenomenal number of
women he was having sex with and how he
would look for good targets his words
not mine and and so on very kind of
Hunter language which today I suspect
someone made a good point actually if
social media had existed when that
interview appeared he'd been Torn to
Pieces by social media and he might have
concentrated his mind and he might have
avoided getting himself into the
problems that that came later and what
he's experiencing now but with also no
social media so this stuff would appear
but nobody moved to cancel Russell Brand
then none of these left-wing
organizations thought this was only
reprehensible now a lot of the same
people because he's now seen as a sort
of alt-right kind of character you know
really adopted by the conservatives now
a lot of people on the left who's
happily saluted and celebrated him
knowing what he was admitting in public
about his activities then now
revisionously going back and feigning in
my view moral outrage over what he was
admitting to then I don't think you can
do that
certainly people are comparing this to a
Soviet show trial to a kangaroo court
where where the people are convicted
before any evidence is presented and I
think that's a good analogy because I
think it explains why these guys get off
the hook for all of their improprieties
for so long and that's so that people
have compromise on them you know the so
that they put themselves in compromising
positions and they get away with it
until they stop Towing the party line
and then all of a sudden it becomes a
political attack you see even in the
time story that came out the the the big
transgression here seems to have been
more political than sexual because the
women say they were only motivated to
speak out when they were contacted by
journalists it's it's not as though they
ran to law enforcement it's not as
though they penned an essay on sub stack
or medium or something like that this
was a decision that was made within the
media it's obviously a political
decision because newspaper editors are
political figures and the way that we
can underscore that is just as soon as
the story came out already the political
figures are getting involved up to and
including Parliament yeah and you see I
mean you see a lot of double standard I
think in for example the way that Donald
Trump has been treated over his alleged
misdemeanors and the way uh Joe Biden
has over the hunter Biden laptop Scandal
and so on completely different set of
Standards you know when Trump for
example is found with a classified
documents it's the worst thing of all
time and it's pretty serious but when
they're finding Joe Biden's garage you
know the same journalists who've been so
incensed by Trump's uh keeping of these
documents almost don't want to don't
want to acknowledge that Biden's done
the same thing
well don't forget peers they first tried
to impeach Donald Trump for colluding
with the Russians and then that
investigation the Mueller investigation
went absolutely nowhere so they flipped
and decided they were going to impeach
Donald Trump for colluding with the
ukrainians and the subject was that
Donald Trump had some kind of untoward
improper phone call with the leader of
Ukraine and the Supreme irony here is
while Donald Trump had a perfectly fine
phone call we now know for a fact that
Joe Biden did exert extreme political
pressure on Ukraine in fact he set up
phone calls with the president of
Ukraine under pseudonym pseudonyms
through which he was involved in his
son's crooked business deals some was
earning millions of dollars sitting on
the board of Ukrainian and Energy
company for which he had
he had a lutely zero experience I mean
it's a more blatant form of corruption
when your father's vice president with
specific interest in Ukraine it's hard
to imagine
Joe Biden's attorney general just came
out yesterday Merrick Garland and he
said with a straight face you got to
give him credit for being a supreme
actor he said that there's only one
system of justice in the United States
not two tiers of Justice at the same
time he's ducking questions about the
FBI targeting Catholics about the FBI
targeting parents and then the the most
farcical aspect of it all which is that
for the first time in American history a
former president is being indicted the
leader of the opposition is currently
being indicted meanwhile you've got far
more evidence of far more egregious
crimes from the sitting president of the
United States and what do they do they
slap the son Hunter Biden with no more
than a minor gun charge of all the
crimes that we've seen this guy commit
on terabytes on his computer they hit
him on the gun charge the one crime that
doesn't implicate his father yeah total
corruption an astonishing coincidence
you might not think uh great to talk to
you Michael thank you very much
beer it's great to be with you thanks
for having me well I said to the next my
boss Rupert Murdoch who owns talk TV is
making some moves of his own I'll give
you my take on that in a moment
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to Facebook uncensored now
my boss Rupert Murdoch uh he's been my
boss on and off for 30 years he's been a
Visionary leader his audacity and
tenacity has helped build a
magnificently successful Global media
Empire and I've enjoyed working with him
and learning from him a little earlier
today he announced his transitioning to
the role of chairman emeritus a fox and
news Corps and passing control of the
companies to his son Lockton he said in
a statement to staff our companies are
in robust Health as am I our
opportunities far exceed our commercial
challenges with every reason to be
optimistic about the coming years I
certainly am and plan to be here to
participate in them but the battle the
freedom of speech and ultimately the
freedom of thought has never been more
intense
here here boss well for more I'm joined
by Fox News contributor Joe concert Joe
a big moment for us in the two companies
uh I don't know about you when I heard
this it was like I did I didn't ever
think I'd hear the day that Rupert
Murdoch would stand aside and hang
control to someone else like this but it
is his son who's been right by his side
now for a number of years what do you
make of it
I make that this is an epic run to end
all Epic runs peers I mean you think
about how long Rupert Murdoch has been
at the top of the media business we're
talking seven decades he was running
newspapers before John F Kennedy was
running the United States we're going
all the way back to the 50s and you
think about it's not just newspapers
it's Sports it's media it's news it's it
it's every type of type of broadcasting
that you can do as far as media
conglomerates are concerned and but when
you think about what he did with Fox
News for example launches at 1996 smart
enough to hire an innovator like Roger
Ailes who then took this network which
many people thought would crash and burn
in a year or two in 1996 by 2001
surpassed CNN which was the only player
on the Block and for 25 years basically
since has been number one by a country
mile so you see the profits you see the
success here in the United States
Australia Britain and across the world
and you can't find probably somebody
who's been more successful in the media
business than Rupert Murray no I think
he's been the greatest of them all I
really do and the thing I've always
loved about Rupert is he's a risk taker
and a Visionary he sees something 10
years ahead and he'll bet the bank on it
and almost invariably he it works you
know not always but it invariably over
those decades again and again and again
he's backed himself and I think that's
an extraordinary gift that some people
have
um in his statement he says for my
entire professional life I've been
engaged daily with news and ideas that
won't change he talks about uh Lachlan
taking over a principal passionate
leader who becomes sole chairman of both
companies he said here neither excessive
Pride nor false humility are admirable
colleagues but I'm truly proud of what
we've achieved collectively through the
decades and I owe much to my colleagues
whose contributions to success and
sometimes being unseen and any sites I
really like this line whether the truck
drivers Distributing our papers the
cleaners you toil when we've left the
office the assistance who support us or
the skilled operators behind the cameras
or the computer code we will be less
successful and have less positive impact
on society without your day-to-day
dedication he talked about how his
father believed firmly in Freedom
Lachlan is equally committed as Rupert
is to that cause of freedom but there
was a great line because people have
been seeing Mrs retirement and I was
like I've known Rupert Murdoch a long
time three decades
I can't ever imagine it just lying on a
beach retired it's not going to happen
and there's a great telling line in the
statement which confirms my belief he
said I'll be watching our broadcast with
a critical eye he's probably watching
this now uh reading our newspapers and
websites and books with much interest
and reaching out to you with thoughts
ideas and advice when I visit your
countries and companies you can expect
to see them in the office late on a
Friday afternoon and he said that
because he's got a real bug bear about
this this trend in America of people
just bunking off on a Friday so Rupert's
going to be still prowling around the
newsrooms uh and the and the offices of
fox I'm sure and here at talk TV on a
Friday night just to check we're putting
a shift in uh a remarkable guy
incredible work ethic uh incredible
Drive uh I think that he loves
newspapers he loves television he loves
politics he loves the media you know
he's someone who I think uh you know
I've certainly had enormous respect and
admiration for for a very long time and
I've got a lot to be grateful to him for
you know he may be editor of his biggest
selling newspaper the news of the world
when I was 28 years old
and he rehired me a couple of years ago
to come and do a number of things for
him this show being one of them columns
for his papers the Sun the New York Post
crime documentaries for Fox Nation
they've just dropped there you know a
book for harpercollins so that shows you
his reach he was able to offer me
everything I do in my entire life Rupert
was able to give me that on his
platforms and that shows you the kind of
Global Firepower he's built with that
company or both companies
then Rupert and uh appears I don't think
it was totally about money I mean
obviously you have to make money for
your shareholders this is a business but
I think you nailed it as far as it was a
labor of love that he had a passion for
this business a passion for new ideas
and Innovation and that's why we saw the
success that fox had because it's not
about you're right he's not the type of
guy who's now just going to go off in
the sunset and retire he'll probably
still be very active in terms of the
exchange of those ideas moving forward
he reminds me of you quite frankly I I
can't see you ever retiring from this
business because you wake up every day
and you want to go to work well also it
doesn't feel like work I always say to
my sons you know that one's one's a
journalist actually and others an actor
they both love their their staff and the
youngest ones just left University I
said if you find a job you love it
actually never feels like work I doubt
Rupert's ever woken up and thought I've
got to go to work I think he works
incredibly hard at something he loves to
do and that's how I always view him and
I'm sure he'll just continue now because
the the burning thing that he has which
I think is is what makes all great
journalists actually he's got intense
curiosity
you know I saw the former editor of the
Sun in Scotland uh Gordon smart he was
talking about a car Journey he had with
Rupert when he was running the things up
to Scotland and just in this car Journey
as they drove around Scotland Rupert was
peppering him with just endless
questions about Scottish issues about
architecture about football about
politics about media and you had to be
on it and you had and it really took me
back to when I ran a newspaper for him
is that he had his handle on every
single nut and bolt of your business and
if you did well woe bataiji and that's
how he became so successful and that's
why people love working for it because
ultimately if you shared that philosophy
of hard work graft have a bit of fun but
win and winning was always the driving
motivating thing I think then you would
always get on great with Rupert no
problem at all but I've got a lot to be
grateful to him for I sent him a note
today saying how grateful I am how
influential he's been on my life you
know for a long long time and so it was
quite a moment today I gotta say uh Joe
I appreciate you joining me thank you
it's it's a big moment for the company
but I know Lachlan since he was a
teenager uh a very very impressive man
who's been right at the right hand of
his father now for quite a while uh
running the show and I've got absolutely
no doubt he's going to be great too so I
think we're in good hands
thanks Paris I agree all the best honor
and upward yep absolutely I'm joined
about my parents talk to the
international editor Isabel Oak Sean
talk to me contributor Paula Roan Adrian
quite a moment I think for all of us oh
definitely I mean I joined the Sunday
Times in 2006 not quite your length of
service but you know Rupert Murdoch has
been such a massive figure in journalism
all this time and
um I I loved his statement you know the
bit about the cleaners what a beautiful
touch and how how much politicians could
learn from that right because they so
often forget the so-called little people
who are not little people at all they
are absolutely integral to the running
of the place but the other bit I loved
was his comment about the importance of
freedom of speech and how it is under
threat like never before and in the time
that he has been in this industry just
in fact if we even narrow it to the last
five years I don't think there's ever
been such a threat to freedom of speech
no I certainly because there is now no
and actually the reason I came back to
work for him was because he was he
shared my sort of Fury about what had
gone on Good Morning Britain but Meghan
Markle and the the sort of suppression
of free speech my ability to express
opinions and I and he shared my view was
ridiculous so the mission is more
important than ever actually no question
no question Paula I mean on the left he
could be a bit of a demon figure he's
always I think quite enjoyed that
rattling the old Lefty cages but what's
your view about this news today I'm not
sure that you can limit his
controversies to the left actually
appears and I think in in reacting to
this whole concern about freedom of
speech it's important also to reference
the fact that he is a controversial
character to many yeah um but the fact
is for me Rupert Murdoch isn't just
about uh sport he's not just about news
he's about how we now watch TV and and
you know you can remember the sky boxes
going off on people's houses it was
massive well Premier League football is
because of Rupa murder yeah and people
do not give him enough credit for that
yeah he basically it was a great
documentary series recently it was down
to him and Alan sugar Lord sugar now and
his ability to put the satellite dishes
up the combination brought football
kicking and screaming into the Brave New
World that we now take for granted it's
the best league in the world that was
down to Rupert and at 92 years young we
cannot imagine for a moment that he
would dare anyone to challenge him about
the fact that he was just going to walk
all day he's not he's not
walking up I don't know what you call
him it's not retirement uh I can assure
you of that he'll be in touch I'm sure
as much as he's ever been
um let's move on let's go to a story
that I'm sure would have him shaking his
head
um if he's watching this the guardian of
course it's the guardian has a report a
rambler's report basically saying that
our Countryside is racist because the
whitest areas enjoy 144 more local
footballs than the most ethically
diverse areas I mean this is beyond
parody isn't it I mean it could only be
the garden a load of rambling absolute
rambling nonsense yes I mean of course
it's no surprise that the most affluent
areas where there are least dense
population are going to have more paths
why you need why they feel the need to
actually add some ethnicity Dimension to
that I don't know I mean it's just it's
just a desperate publicity Paula you you
often defend the utterly and defensible
on this program have you got valiantly
have you got any defense for the
Guardians Revelation that our
Countryside is racist it's not that I
defend the indefensible is that I'm
right
are you defending this though you have
to understand it is the Rambler
Association it was a fantastic piece of
research and it not only spoke about who
we are where we are it's also spoke
about what good can come from Rambling
what good can come from being outside in
in in the fresh air rambling you don't
exist you think the countryside is
racist dude
is
and I appreciate shape that what you
want to do is to suggest that that's
what the Ramblers Association research
was doing but it wasn't it was I read
what it was the old white wealthy and
healthy have access to miles
in the local neighborhoods than poor and
ethically diverse communities
have pointed that out we might just as
well say rev shock Revelation wealthy
people have bigger Gardens
I didn't see them use the word racist by
the way in their research
they're using race they're using race as
the context for the Beast they said why
they didn't that they did well yeah they
referenced colors because that is a
factual context of the research isn't it
racist Ramblers
as I said I didn't see them use the word
race absolutely so do you reference it
because and and let's let's be frank you
want to be able to dismiss this piece of
work but actually I don't think we
should bear in mind what's happening
with Rishi tsuna and his uh throwing
away his um you know the approaches made
in terms of Net Zero I think he's
absolutely right and once again you're
wrong no I'm not I'm not it's absolutely
right what he's got no suggestions
whatever we were going to be car sharing
no no where was the government born
he's rightly worked out that actually a
lot of people in this country do not
ideologically agree with that we have to
move to a more Net Zero world but you
can't do it at such a pace everyone runs
out of cash and right is is left
destitute you can't do it anyway move
let's move on I've said my piece on that
um
we're gonna talk about stiff upper lip
there's a survey coming out a
cambridge's studies revealed that having
a stiff upper lip a suppressing negative
thoughts is good for mental health
analysis of 120 people trained to
suppress their thoughts found the modern
approach of addressing trauma and
problems can be worse than burying them
internally really interesting this
because I've had a real theory about
this for a while that's good I know it's
been contentious but I don't think it is
that contentious because I come from a
family where this is how we've dealt
with stuff and we don't feel like we've
missed out because we're not constantly
doing it a different way but I do feel
that the idea of stiff upper lip concept
of it which by the way the queen did
better than anybody right the idea that
somehow this has become a bad thing that
we should frown upon this survey
actually says the opposite but sometimes
actually deploying that can actually be
helpful to people now I want to talk to
you about this uh Isabel because I know
you've just been through a really sad
moment in your life your mother has just
died yes and
you've come into work which is a kind of
an example of this really so tell me how
you feel it well first of all my
honestly I said to you at the moment I'm
so sorry because I know that you've lost
both your parents now it's a big moment
in someone's life it is but she was a
good old age so what I always try to do
is try to think of the good things
um and I'm also trying to bring my
children up to be resilient because I
think resilience is hugely important
huge you know you can choose to
interpret setbacks in different ways and
my dad always had an expression I've had
a minor setback you would say and it
could often be something pretty big but
it's about how you react to What happens
you know you can't always control what
happens people die but what is your
response to it going to be
um and I'm choosing to Soldier on
um and it doesn't mean that I'm not
going to have some tearful moments
um but actually coming onto this show
we're having a really interesting debate
and I'm surrounded by bright lights and
friendly people and that's great needs
um and people deal with stuff in
different ways don't they but if you
ever want a case study in how endless
therapy and Naval gazing doesn't work
you only have to look at our Harry don't
you Prince Harry well yeah I I do think
that the constant obsessive conversation
about it can actually have the opposite
effect and what's interesting Paul about
the survey it seems to suggest the same
thing people in 16 countries we're asked
to think about 20 different fears of
Warriors they thought might happen 20
hopes and dreams and 36 hundred
scenarios data show that those told
explicitly to not think about the events
or distract themselves from thinking
about them thought about their events
less vividly and improved their mental
health in other words if you do just
obsess with this and I would also add in
the whole dopamine element to modern
society where kids are being exposed all
the time to really violent horrible
imagery whether it's pornography or War
graphic War the constant constant
constant sharing sharing sharing all
this stuff you put all this together and
you you end up in a real messy place I
think oh absolutely and to be frank that
research it is not unusual there's been
research since about 1987 that's been
conducted on this suppression
um the body the brain naturally
suppresses bad
um traumatic events that's what it does
that's how we protect ourselves and CBT
was actually born out of that research
of tried to teach you how to manage
those triggering events so um in terms
of that research it's not that unusual
but what I would be interested to
understand is whether the 120 subjects
actually suffered traumatic events I'm
not clear and I think the jury is still
out on whether actually the suppression
works for uh trauma really big stuff
yeah I mean for example
um PTSD or you know of course but I've
always said obviously that's extreme
cases yes yes I I just think generally
we don't prepare young people for real
life we don't very well anymore we
stopped doing it you know and it's
little things like but if if it should
do that and this is the problem
ultimately who is responsible for doing
that parents actually
um actually no I think I actually think
the me I think the media actually
collectively you mean who is at fault
well no no I I do mean to be responsible
for teaching children to be resilient
well I I would honestly change the way
we teach kids at school I mean first
thing I do if I was running to schools
in this country no more participation
prizes if Little Johnny comes last in a
race he doesn't get anything he
understands but the winning and losing
right and you have to compete in life
because when you get out of school
there's no one protecting you a bit of a
shot people kids don't they're not used
to losing anything the exams are
competing peers so they do understand
the concept of competition yeah but not
really and I think we cost at them we
protect them too much and then they they
in the end they're just ill prepared for
the harsh reality of the tough real
world which is tough you know very very
tough um anyway look we've got to leave
it um but my my deepest sympathies to
you and I really appreciate you coming
in and we'll dedicate this show to your
mum
is at the White House to call for more
U.S banking for Ukraine but can he win
over Republicans who say it's costing
too much U.S presidential candidate will
Hurd is up next
foreign
[Music]
Trump yeah look at him fail about
working just because their skin folk
don't mean they're kinfolks do you
believe you can win this wall this is
making me cry again I'm trying to force
you out yes I feel betrayed keep it
award-winning
Lucy latty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I honestly wish I'd never met
him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to pivotal Grand Central
Ukraine's president zielinski is in
Washington aiming to secure another 24
billion dollars in aid from the United
States he's visited the capital just
arrived at the White House for an
audience with President Biden so let's
get to battle to win over skeptical
Republicans Congress has already
authorized more than 110 billion dollars
since Russia's Invasion some Republicans
warn they will oppose further spending
on the war which zelenski believes could
cost him the war we're joining me now to
discuss all this is Sarah Brown who just
returned from Ukraine I've visited with
their world a children's education
charity and the Republican presidential
candidate Will Herb well first of all
Sarah you've just been to Ukraine I went
there over a year ago now and spent time
with the president and the first lady
um things were relatively quiet there
but we've now another year in
under particularly devastating toll on
kids tell me about that
well families are needing to move to
places of safety so children's schooling
is getting disrupted and they're going
through you know quite harrowing times I
mean having been in Kiev uh just last
week meeting with president zelensky and
and the first lady you can see that that
city is really feeling the pressures of
it but they also as a community of
people feel that they're all in it
together and everyone playing their part
but for children that means families are
moving away from the front line moving
away from the more dangerous areas
schooling is getting disrupted so
there's a big push behind we've been
working from their world to make sure
that 70 000 laptops are getting out
there software's on there learning
materials are on there so that even if
they're on the Move they're able to
continue learning but the meeting with
president zielinski that we had was his
focus is also to think about the
youngest children the ones that are
preschool and I think we've learned a
lot from other conflicts other disasters
that we can't ignore the youngest
children that we need to be invest in
them and it's really interesting to me
that Ukraine is wanting to move faster
and do more at an earlier stage than
we've seen in other conflicts around the
world before right I mean 19
000 Ukrainian children are believed to
have been taken to Russia or occupied
territory since the War Began they're
just disappearing in vast numbers
yeah knowing where children are knowing
that families are safe I mean obviously
in the Eastern side of Ukraine there are
families who you know that's been the
connections they have people are moving
to where they think there isn't fighting
and where there's conflict but there are
many many other families who have been
moving West but the other thing that's
interesting is families often leave
Ukraine maybe they're staying in Hungary
or Poland or Moldova but also when they
think it's a little bit safer they're
going back so I think for president
zielinski and certainly the
organizations like mine that are working
to help deliver Education Services and
support in that crisis we're looking for
where children are and understanding
that they're not always staying in one
place so needing to be really smart
about how we create safe spaces for
children to be able to learn you know
you've been talking this morning this
afternoon about how families and
children you know their resilience at
school whether where they can put up
with the ups and downs of it these are
children that are really going through
ups and downs and learning you know
resilience the hard way and there needs
to be a stability that goes in there you
know there's a bit more effort going
into schooling in around maths and
Science and just getting some of those
core subjects going so they're not
losing at all every Ukrainian has this
dream of how they will go back and
rebuild that country you know we have
the allyship the United Kingdom from the
USA other countries coming to you know
help defend that country that's under
attack and some of that defense has to
be protecting children and also those
really little children
um 90 of the brain is developing in
those first three years you know you
want children who are growing that
environment to have that support have
child care look at what you know their
parents are doing during the day where
are the children in a safe space and
what are the learning programs that are
being delivered for them yeah well their
world does some fantastic work so thank
you Sarah I appreciate you joining the
program tonight I've done it will hurt
Republican Republican presidential
candidate well it's obvious now from the
rhetoric coming out of president
zielinski in Washington today that he
believes if the United States was to
suddenly pull funding then that could
cost him the war simple as that why are
so many Republicans increasing numbers
of Republicans why are they so resistant
to this given that effectively they're
fighting for freedom and democracy
against a Russian dictator
well it's unfortunate that that there's
too many people in my party that are
more interested in pushing a Russian
propaganda than actually talking about
how we defend the Free World I'm of the
opinion that they have forgotten the
fact that the United States and our
allies have built an international order
that benefits us and when we don't
defend that order it hurts us they've
also failed to understand the difference
between our friends and our enemies let
me be very clear if Vladimir Putin is a
war criminal are you and Mrs Brown just
talked about how the impact this is
having on on children and we should be
doing everything to stop him my
frustrations is actually we're not
getting the support and the aid to the
ukrainians fast enough in order to
prevent this from becoming a Forever War
nobody wants that and then we also want
to make sure that the resources that are
being used are being properly accounted
for but but the United States would
never fight a war this way uh without
having air superiority without with
having restrictions on the use of of
Munitions on the ground uh we should not
have those those requirements
um and and in order to make sure that
we're defending freedom and democracy I
also think there's a concern I would
have certainly that if the United States
was just to pull out and and stop
sending Aid to Ukraine and some of your
rival candidates you know to be the
Republican nominee have advocated this I
mean let's take a look at a little
mashup we did of some of them here
why are you against supporting agree
because it does not Advance American
interests well they have effectively a
blank check policy with no clear
strategic objective identified and these
things can can escalate and I don't
think it's in our interest the United
States needs to be pushing for peace in
Ukraine not funding a proxy war with
Russia the Biden Administration is sleep
walking our great country into a World
War
I mean I you know I'm funded baffling
the senior Republicans talk like that
about something like this when it seems
to be so clear-cut Russian dictator
invades Sovereign Democratic country
steals land murders people in virtual
genocide
why would a Republican
think that that is a good thing or not
want to immediately help repel him
uh well Piers uh we need to invite you
to speak in front of Congress because
you're you're absolutely right and and
to me it's sickening the fact that even
Donald Trump Ron DeSantis of Vivek Rama
Swami uh the fact that they do not
understand that that Vladimir Putin is a
war criminal that they're more
interested in kissing his butt uh than
actually trying to defeat him uh to me
is just is just is is wrong
um I've spent a decade overseas I was in
the CIA my job was to stop terrorists
from blowing up our homeland to put
Russian spies and Chinese spies prevent
them from stealing our secrets and uh to
print uh nuclear weapons proliferators
from from doing their their trade and
having real world experience on this
um we we have to remember that if
Ukraine loses then Eastern Europe is
gone they're back into the orbit of
Russia Western Europe is not going to
care about the United States and they're
going to Cozy up with the Chinese
government the United States and our
allies are in a new cold war with the
Chinese Communist party and what happens
in Ukraine potentially is going to show
what's going to potentially happen in
Taiwan as well and the fact that there's
too many people that understand
that this isolationist streak it
actually hurts America is frustrating
and it comes down to their lack of
experience in in foreign policy and
their failure to understand how the
world actually works and when you hear
Donald Trump say oh I would fix it all
in one day I mean how's he going to do
that well let me actually got the clip
here let's watch this
I would get him into a room I'd get
zelinski into a room then I'd bring them
together and I'd have the deal worked
out essentially for four years I kept
them from doing anything Ukraine was the
apple of his eye
I said don't ever do it don't ever do it
he would have never done it the war
would have never happened
you see I just think that's so
disingenuous of Donald Trump because
there's no way this can be reconciled by
just getting zelenski and Putin into a
room now because ultimately few team
will want to keep the Landes stolen so
landscape will want to get it back
there's no peace deal to be done right
now it seems to me
the appears are you implying that Donald
Trump is lying uh of course he is he you
know in in this case uh the fact that he
thinks he's going to be able to solve
this problem is just one more lie this
is this not one more example of why I
think Donald Trump is running for
president to stay out of prison uh not
to make a America great again and and
the reality is this I believe when we
talk about what is success in this case
it is pushing the Russians out of all of
Ukraine to include the dambos and Crimea
and it's up to the Ukrainian people to
decide uh what any kind of future peace
offering and we know that the Ukrainian
people are resilient and are not going
to accept anything less
um than the the full evacuation of the
Russians and and what the other thing
that's frustrating is at a time that we
know that the Russians are vulnerable
the fact that Vladimir Putin has to go
to North Korea and Kim Jong-un in order
to buy old outdated equipment because
things are going so poorly for him when
he just had an Insurgency a former
General barreling down to come to Moscow
to kick him out of power the fact that
that Vladimir Putin is dealing with all
this is the time for all of us to
reinvest in what the ukrainians are
doing to help the ukrainians win this
war and and push Russia out well heard I
could not agree with you more honestly I
I'm completely baffled like I said at
the start of this that more Republicans
I mean some obviously many Republicans
do share your view but it's alarming to
me to see the rising number don't and
don't see the bigger picture here you
know China's watching all this thinking
well what's America going to do if
America just bails out now on Ukraine
that is a red that's just a there's a
red flag to the world but it's a green
flag to China okay well let's go and
take Taiwan then what's going to happen
not a lot we've run out of time will I'm
I was a rhetorical statement to end it
but I do appreciate you joining me thank
you very much
of course
well since the next 10 year old
Australian comic has gone viral around
the world that's leaving TV presenters
in stitches with a brutal joke about
vegans he's up next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
industry reeling from the Russell Brand
Scandal warns of further misogyny and
abuse allegations to come a new British
survey finds social class is seen as a
bigger barrier now than it was in the
80s and channel 4's boss slams gen Z
youngsters for their reluctance to
debate discuss and disagree expect a lot
of that at nine o'clock
good
Australia's top rated Today's show has
exploded online in the last few weeks
after they've decided to tell my old
friend Carl stefanovic and his co-host
Sarah a little joke this was their
reaction to his joke hahaha
we weren't expecting that
so what exactly did Young Byron say that
caused those two to corpse in that
manner well who better to ask than the
man himself I'm joined from Sydney by
Baron Baron how are you
you're not too bad yourself piss I'm
good mate and you are the most famous
young man in Australia after cracking
the joke that reduced the Today show
host to quivering wrecks of laughter so
for the benefit of our viewers what was
the joke a vegan and a vegetarian are
jumping off a cliff to see or hit the
bottom first who wins I don't know who
wins
Society
[Laughter]
it is a very very funny joke I mean
obviously vegans and vegetarians won't
last but they never laugh at anything
because they never eat enough meat so
they're always hungry is it giving you
the the Temptation now to become a
comedian when you get older
um yeah any other jokes up your sleeve
back in your day
you had one woman
in my
we wonder if it is a woman
Byron you have a very very near the
knuckle humor for a young lad but I like
it uh it's great to see you best of luck
with your comedy career and
congratulations on what you did to Carl
because he's an old friend of mine and
I've not seen him reduced to a state
like that in a very long time so
congratulations
thank you
I loved his dead pound delivery didn't
you someone asked me earlier what's your
favorite joke when I was his age I had a
joke it was what did a hypochondriac
have written on his tombstone
told you I was ill and then cut forwards
when I ran the daily mirrors editor and
Spike Milligan died and when he died it
turned out he'd used this joke and so we
did a tombstone front page with the joke
and his widow rang me a few days later
and said she loved it so much could she
have a copy which I loved so we sent her
a copy and that was how we remember
Spike so jokes they always come around
like generationally but I think that
kid's got a big future
um that's it for me whatever you're up
to Keep It Uncensored and a final
message to the boss Rupa murder what an
amazing career I know you're not
completely going but today is a day
where we salute you and what you've
achieved and we thank you everyone who
works for you for being the greatest
Titan in media that I think there's ever
been and I for one and personally
incredibly grateful to you Rupert Murdo
of everything you've done for me so
thank you good night
thank you
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
Cube I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just cause
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but you're making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning Ma
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls oh
[Music]